i'm at this point to bring you our
committed coverage of encore book notes
tonight author doris kearns goodwill
about the world are dependent on
doris kearns goodwin author of no
ordinary time
if you could ask either franklin delano
roosevelt or eleanor roosevelt a couple
of questions after all the work he did
on this book what would they be i think
with eleanor i'd like to understand why
she was unable at a certain moment in
the middle of the war when he asked her
to be his wife again and stop traveling
and stay home and take care of him to
say yes to him i mean i know that he
loved her i know she still loved him and
i'd want to say why didn't you do it
he's going to die soon i wish you had
done it
and i think for him i'd want to
understand why he couldn't share himself
more fully with anyone he was the most
ebullient most charming most sparkling
personality on the surface everybody
thought how warm he was but underneath
there was such reserve in him and i'd
want to try and understand why that was
so and why he couldn't give himself more
to the people who loved him
what makes this book different than all
the rest
well i think what i wanted to do in this
book was to understand not only franklin
and eleanor's relationship which has
been looked at in many many other cases
but to understand the whole extended
family that surrounded them in the white
house and i came to an understanding
that these two characters really both
needed other people to meet the untended
needs that were left over as a result of
their troubled marriage so what i came
upon was a sense that the second family
quarters of the white house were really
like a residential hotel during these
years and there's about seven people
living there all of whom are intimate
friends of either franklin or eleanor's
that was the part that was new and fun
for me
if you had to ask a question of either
one of them about personal relationships
that they had with other people who
would you be most interested in i think
the person that i'm interested in for
franklin is not simply lucy mercer who
everybody assumes is the central
romantic figure in his life because she
had an affair with him back in 1918 and
it almost broke up eleanor's marriage
but there's another woman that i think
had an even more central role to play in
his life and that was his secretary
missy lahand she had started working for
him when she was only 20 years old in
1920 she loved him all the rest of her
life she never married and everybody in
washington knew that she was really his
other wife when eleanor traveled which
she did like 200 or 250 days a year
she was the one who took care of
roosevelt if he had a cold she'd bring
in the cough medicine to the white house
if he were grumpy during the day she'd
arrange a poker game at night he had
this cocktail hour every night and
somehow she'd be the one to be his
hostess she really was on a daily basis
the closest person in the world to him
that's the relationship i'd like to know
more about
you have in the book this
second floor scenario
and we'll get a closer shot here on some
of these names
why did you put this in the book well it
seemed to me that what the reader was
going to get from reading the book was i
hoped a sense of what it was like 50
years ago to be in the white house and
because each of these rooms was occupied
by somebody who was very important to
either franklin or eleanor their closest
friends in some case romantic friends i
wanted everybody to see how close they
were to see that they could wander
around in the middle of the quarters at
night and actually talk to one another
what year was this this was 1940 to 1945
so these rooms depict that period at
that time
as you can see here on the one end um
you have eleanor roosevelt's bedroom
and right across the hall is lorena
hickok right now who who was lorena
hickok and what was their relationship
this was the second floor of the white
house right lorena hickok had been a
former reporter for the associated press
and in fact in 1933 she was considered
the leading female reporter in the
country she weighed about 200 pounds she
smoked cigars she played poker with the
guys and she was really smart and what
happened is she came to interview
franklin and eleanor during the campaign
in 32 and eleanor and she became really
close friends she fell in love with
eleanor and more importantly she
probably helped eleanor become the
activist first lady that she did it was
lorena who came up with the idea of
eleanor holding press conferences every
week only female reporters could come so
a whole generation of female journalists
got their start because every newspaper
had to hire a female reporter she was
the one who came up with the idea of a
syndicated column that eleanor wrote
every day
missing only the day that her husband
died and really helped eleanor transform
the role of the first lady from a
ceremonial to an activist one and in the
course of that she did fall in love with
eleanor eleanor i don't think fully
reciprocated it but they were close
enough friends that she wanted her
living nearby so she lived in the white
house the entire time during the war
also on this second floor uh
schematic is uh
the you have a room in which harry
hopkins lived in and how long did he
live in there and who was he well harry
hopkins had been roosevelt's chief
new deal man in a certain sense during
the 1930s he was the head of the work
progress administration he'd been a
social worker originally but when the
war broke out in europe in may of 1940
hopkins was staying overnight that night
at the white house and roosevelt decided
that he wanted him nearby he didn't want
him to go home he needed somebody that
he could talk to first thing in the
morning talk to late at night and he
made hopkins his chief adviser on
foreign policy hopkins went to see
churchill before roosevelt met him went
to see stalin before roosevelt met him
was really unprecedented in terms i mean
he makes kissinger look like a
mild-mannered guy in terms of the kind
of power that hopkins had and he was
incredibly loyal to roosevelt how long
did he live on the second floor of the
white house he was there from 1940 to
1942
end of 42 when he got married and
roosevelt was sad when he eventually
stayed there for about six months with
his new wife but then she finally wanted
a house of her own
here's another bedroom it's called the
rose room and you see show that to mr
churchill
sarah who is
roosevelt's mother the indomitable
mother and martha right well that's a
pretty interesting room that room first
whenever the mother came she wanted the
best bedrooms bedroom suite and that was
this room the rose suite she would come
to visit him maybe once a month with her
maids and her servants and always being
a duchess in a certain sense in the
white house and then also princess
martha was an interesting character who
she had come to washington during the
war years in exile from norway her
husband was the crown prince and her
father-in-law was the king of norway in
fact her son is currently the king of
norway now she was beautiful she was
long-legged roosevelt always liked his
women tall or so it seems and i think
she had a gay spirited kind of
conversation that he just enjoyed and
eleanor somehow understood that he
needed that kind of companionship so she
would visit on weekends and keep him
company in the movies keep him company
at dinners at night often again when
eleanor was away and this would be her
suite but when churchill came no one
else stayed in the suite churchill was
an incredible character during this
period of time he would come and stay
for like three or four weeks at a time
and his habits were so exhausting that
nobody else could sleep during the
period of time he was there he would
awaken in the morning and have wine for
breakfast he would have scotch and soda
for lunch he would have brandy at night
smoking his cigars until 2am and when he
would finally leave after being in this
suite for three or four weeks the entire
white house staff would have to sleep
for 72 hours in order to recuperate from
churchill's visits you mentioned uh you
had in quote marks in the book that the
relationship between princess martha of
norway and fdr was romantic
some of the people who lived in the
white house at that time suggested that
she was his girlfriend that there was a
real flirtation between the two and i
suspect that that's what the element of
the relationship was it wasn't somebody
he was working with like missy lehand it
wasn't some political partner it wasn't
some old friend and companion it was a
flirtatious relationship whether it went
beyond you know kissing and romance and
and just a sense of pleasure i don't
know but it certainly was that also you
show that anna stayed in one of those
rooms on the second floor she's there in
this picture in the middle next to her
father
uh what was their relationship well what
had happened is an interesting and i
think in some ways some of the most
moving moments of this period of time
because anna had originally been her
mother's daughter when anna was a young
girl and adolescent eleanor had told her
the story of lucy mercer and the fact
that her father had this affair with
lucy long ago and anna had taken her
mother's side and over the years the two
had grown so close
that they wrote each other letters two
or three times a week and they saw each
other four or five times a year even
when anna lived on the other coast
but what happened is in the middle of
the war
after eleanor rejected franklin's quest
to stay home and be his wife again he
got so lonely that he asked their
daughter anna to come and take missy
lahan's place missy by that point even
though she was only in her early 40s it
had a stroke and she could never speak
again it was one of those devastating
things for roosevelt during the war
years and because he was so lonely
without missy and his mother had also
died just after missy's stroke he asked
anna to come and stay in the white house
and then what happened is in some ways
she became his father's dog her father's
daughter she had long legs she was tall
she loved cocktails she could gossip at
night with him all the things that
eleanor never found it easy to do anna
did and after a while i think eleanor
began to feel displaced by her own
daughter so it was a very complicated
set of relationships that developed
during this time
where do you live concord massachusetts
right on main street right near where it
all began
why conquered
well i think it was a compromise i love
the city i grew up actually outside of
new york and my husband loves the real
country he'd prefer living in maine so
concord seemed to be near enough to
boston that i could have my city life
and near enough to country that he could
feel he was really living outside of the
suburb more country than suburb what's
your husband do his name is richard
goodwin and he's a writer also in fact
just recently he's been involved in the
quiz show scandal movie because his
first job after clerking for justice
frankfurter was to investigate the rig
television quiz shows so he's having a
great time right now he's being
portrayed as a 27 year old actor on the
big screen feeling like decades have
dropped off his life so it's really been
fun but mostly he's a writer where did
you meet him
in harvard i was teaching at harvard um
i taught a course on the presidency and
taught some american government courses
and he came to finish a book and i had
an office at this little kennedy
institute and he had an office right
next to mine so that's how it happened
and you dedicate the book to three
people right who are they three sons
probably the most important people in my
life one is in his mid-20s one is a
freshman at amherst college and the
youngest one thank god is still at home
in high school i don't want it to end i
wish they were four six and eight again
and how many books have you written
three
what were the other two well the first
one was lyndon johnson and the american
dream and that came out of the
experience that i will forever treasure
of having been 23 and 24 years old and
working for president johnson in the
white house and then helping him with
his memoirs i still keep thinking
johnson is still around i keep thinking
he's thinking this book on roosevelt's
is 700 pages the one on me was only 350
pages how can you do that so that was
the first book and was a great
experience to try and understand that
giant of a man who i found so sad in his
retirement while he was at the ranch
that he was almost like he had nothing
else left in his life once politics was
taken from him so that whole experience
i think seared into my mind forever and
made up that first book and then the
second one was called the fitzgeralds
and the kennedys and it was a
three-generation history of the kennedy
family in fact partly made possible by
the fact that i was given access to rose
and joe kennedy's private papers that
had been in the attic for over 50 years
because my husband had originally been
on the white house staff with john
kennedy so we knew the kennedy family so
i think one of the reasons why this book
on the roosevelts means so much is that
it's really the first time i've had to
slog it through as an ordinary historian
without the advantage of knowing lyndon
johnson or knowing the kennedy family so
it's been fun is there new information
in the book oh yes i think definitely
by choosing this period of time and by
focusing on the american home front
rather than the battlefront for all the
thousands of books that have been
written about world war ii there have
been very few that focus on what
happened here at home and most of those
have been essay kind of books like a
chapter on civil rights a chapter on the
japanese incarceration camps on women in
the factories but there had been very
little evidence of trying to understand
roosevelt's leadership how he mobilized
this democracy some ways i think that's
his greatest
contribution in a certain sense to the
war even more than the strategy of the
war itself how he got our country to to
produce the weapons for the war that's
what won the war in lots of ways and
turning around a peace economy an
isolationist economy an economy that was
still in the midst of a depression and
somehow making it so productive is a
great story
where did you find
the white house ushers diaries this was
one of my most incredible tools that was
there for anybody to see they're in the
roosevelt library and they're on
microfiche and what happened is at the
end of the day there'd be a white house
usher who would record everything that
happened during the day roosevelt
awakens at seven has a massage at 7 15
goes to breakfast and then they'd record
who he had lunch with who he had dinner
with and then you could use that as a
foundation to go for example suppose he
had lunch with henry stimson or ickes or
morgenthau i knew that they all had
diaries so i could go to their diaries
to find out what he talked about at
lunch or they'd record that eleanor was
with joe lash and i knew that he had a
diary so in some ways it was like the
detective's tool it was there for
anybody to see they're public but they
hadn't been used before it was so easy
and so wonderful quick definitions who
is ickes harold ickes was the secretary
of the interior whose son is currently
in mr clinton's white house staff and he
was called the old curmudgeon at the
time morgenthau henry morgenthau was the
secretary of the treasury and in fact
he's the subject of one of my favorite
stories in the book because roosevelt
had an annual poker game every year and
it would always be held on the day that
the congress was going to adjourn and
the rule was that whoever was ahead at
the moment the speaker of the house
called to adjourn would win on one
particular night morgenthau is way ahead
when the speaker calls to tell roosevelt
he's adjourning at 9 30. so roosevelt
just pretends that it's somebody else
calling i'm sorry i can't talk to you
i'm in the middle of a poker game they
continue playing until finally at
midnight roosevelt starts winning and he
whispers to an a bring the phone to me
and the aide brings the phone he says oh
mr speaker you're adjourning now that's
fine roosevelt wins the game total
manipulation everything is great until
the next morning henry morgenthau reads
in the newspapers that the congress
actually adjourned at 9 30 and he was so
angry that he actually resigned as
secretary of the treasury until
roosevelt charmed him back into it but
there was a real camaraderie among these
cabinet members at the time they could
play poker together as well as work
together as a matter of fact i remember
somebody else resigning at one point and
fdr wrote him a letter and then he
writes back i don't know i can find it
actually where and then he says i got
fluttery all over
i mean it's talked that way amazing i
mean that's right i mean icky's resigned
several times he'd get upset about
policy issues and he would resign so
roosevelt wrote him a very um gracious
letter saying you can't resign i need
you you're so important to me and you're
absolutely right ikki's then wrote back
saying when i read your letter i got
fluttery all over i couldn't believe it
they did talk that way and it showed the
kind of
awe in some ways that they felt for this
man who was still their president they
found it it just says your letter icky's
gratefully replied makes me feel all
fluttery to have you write about me as
you did is like an accolade to my spirit
and it goes on i know
now
how did you go about this where did you
work i worked in terms of research
largely at the roosevelt library and the
wonderful thing that's in hyde park new
york is that it made you feel like you
were going back in time because the
place the house where roosevelt was born
the place that was eleanor's cottage of
balkail looks exactly as it looked when
they were there so sometimes when you're
in the middle of working in a library
room and you take a walk around these
environments you can really feel like
you're back 50 years in time it was so
wonderful and then there were these
little motels around the area that you
stay in right across from the roosevelt
library and you do feel like this is
what a scholar is supposed to be doing
living right at the place where your
subjects live themselves
where is the library it's in hyde park
new york so for me from concord
massachusetts it was about a three and a
half hour drive beautiful drive in the
hudson river far below the house where
roosevelt was born which sits only a few
feet from the library is this beautiful
house that has a great lawn that goes
down to the hudson river far below so
you're surrounded by beauty while you're
doing this kind of old-fashioned
research you mentioned valkyl what's
that well what happened is that's the
cottage that roosevelt had built for
eleanor and in typical aristocratic
terms a cottage actually was 22 rooms it
wasn't a small little cottage but what
happened is in the 1920s after his
affair with lucy mercer and they decided
to stay together it gave eleanor the
freedom to go outside the marriage to
find fulfillment and she became involved
with a whole group of women who were
activists league of women voters
fighting for reform causes child labor
laws and sarah delano roosevelt
franklin's mother always looked to
scance at these women they would come
into the house with their saddle shoes
on and their tweed outfits and they
weren't the kind of fancy people that
she was used to so eleanor didn't feel
comfortable bringing her women political
friends to the big house where franklin
had sarah lived i just want to show the
picture here of mrs roosevelt the mother
in the middle and that's the perfect
symbolic picture in the middle when
franklin went to hide went to harvard
she got a townhouse in boston to be near
him when franklin and eleanor got
married sarah got two townhouses in new
york one for her one for them and doors
went right in between so anyway what
happened is roosevelt seeing how
uncomfortable eleanor felt about having
her friends in the big house suggested
that he would build her her own cottage
and it turned out to be this beautiful
22 room house about a mile and a half or
so from the big house and it allowed
eleanor for the first time in her life
to have a home of her own so she loved
the place and after he died she actually
lived on that place until she herself
died
now if you're coming if somebody's never
been to that part of the country
how far from new york city probably a
couple hours from new york city i know
by train it is on the hudson river along
the hudson river
in duchess county
and
in those years in the war years that
you're writing about here
and domestically where did franklin
delano roosevelt and eleanor roosevelt
spend their time besides the white house
and hyde park well hyde park was the
most important place for both of them i
mean he went during the whole presidency
something like 200 times to hyde park so
that's the most important place would he
get there he would get there by train he
would often get on the train in
washington uh maybe at 10 or 11 at night
and it would reach hyde park by the
morning so he'd be so he'd sleep on the
train he loved traveling by train he had
his own compartment because of his polio
and his paralysis he didn't like fast
moving transportation he hated airplanes
but he could feel grounded on the train
eleanor was just the opposite she liked
to get places fast so she only liked to
travel by plane but she would go with
him by train as well couple quick points
uh
what when did what year did he die 1945.
you remember the exact date april 12th
and
what year did he contract polio and then
have to have the leg irons 1921 when he
was only 37 years old he contracted
polio and i think the one of the things
i understood more by doing this book
than i ever had before was how much that
paralysis was a part of his everyday
life i like so many people in the
country had assumed that he had
conquered the polio somehow and was
simply left a bit lame but in fact he
was a full paraplegic he couldn't even
get out of bed in the morning without
turning his body to the side of the bed
and being helped into his wheelchair by
the valet to get to the bathroom he
couldn't even really walk he had thick
braces on and if he leaned on the arms
of two strong people he could appear to
be maneuvering himself forward and i
think one of my the most extraordinary
moments when i was doing research on the
book i interviewed betsy whitney who had
been married to jimmy roosevelt the
roosevelt's oldest son and she said she
asked him once in the middle of the war
how do you fall asleep at night with all
the burdens that you have to face as
soon as he told her the answer i knew
that that polio was still a huge part of
his imagination because he described
that his own method of counting sheep he
would imagine that he was a young boy
again at hyde park and it was a favorite
sledding hill behind his house which
i've seen from going there that led to
the hudson river far below so in the
presidency as he's falling asleep at
night he would imagine that he was a
young boy again getting on that sled and
he said he knew every curve of the hill
and when he would get the sled to the
bottom of the hill at the river he would
pick it up run to the top and do it over
and over again until he fell asleep as
soon as i heard that i thought my god
this man is the most powerful man in the
world and yet he's imagining when he
falls asleep at night and getting solace
from thinking that he can run sled walk
again the very things that were denied
him at the height of his powers at 37
years old
uh this is a little bit of a diversion
but um and we we need to get the lucy
mercer rutherford story down someplace
here but at one point you you talk about
when he would go from washington to hyde
park he figured out a way to stop and
see her in new jersey that's right she
had an estate in alamouchi new jersey
and he somehow he he loved to figure out
maps anyway he loved old geography thing
so we figured out the railroad lines and
knew that if he went along a different
pattern and he had to convince the
secret service it was safe for him to do
this that he could spend an afternoon
with lucy now this was not until the
last year of his life and i think some
people had assumed and myself included
that he probably had known lucy all of
his life i'd heard about this affair
back in 1918 i knew he'd seen her and
was with her when he died so i thought
maybe it had happened all the way
through that period of time
but the truth was that he had kept his
pledge to eleanor not to see her again
really until the last year of his life
after eleanor had refused to be with him
and be his wife again after anna had
come back into the white house and after
he was diagnosed with congestive heart
failure and i think in that last year of
his night i believe he knew in that last
year that he was dying and he went to
bernard baruch's plantation in and i
guess it was march or april of 44 to
recover and it was there that he saw
lucy mercer essentially for the first
time since 1918 and she had just lost
her husband winthrop rutherford who had
been a very wealthy businessman come
from an old family and so she was
widowed and i believe when he saw her
then that what it did more than anything
was to awaken in him a memory of what it
was like when he was young before the
polio he had known lucy three years
before his polio attack and now before
his heart was giving way and he decided
that he wanted to see her regularly how
was how did he start the original affair
with her she had been a social secretary
working for eleanor what happened is
when he was assistant secretary of the
navy eleanor and franklin moved to
washington in 1914 and eleanor felt
worried about the whole social circle of
invitations that you would get to go to
because you had to know which a-list b
list you belong to go to as assistant
secretary of the navy so she hired this
young woman lucy mercer who came from a
blue blood family in washington and yet
needed money because her father had been
an alcoholic and so lucy came three or
four days a week and worked for the
roosevelts and somewhere in that period
of time between 1914 and 1918 a
relationship developed between lucy and
franklin how long was the affair well as
far as we know it was sometime probably
two or three years in that period of
time between 14 and 18 but it came to an
abrupt end when eleanor happened to come
upon a packet of love letters that lucy
had written to franklin she later said
when she opened these letters that the
bottom fell out of her world and she
actually offered franklin a divorce
immediately but i'm convinced it was the
last thing he wanted i think he had
never meant for the marriage to be over
by his relationship with lucy in some
ways i think lucy's attraction for him
was that she was confident she was gay
she was easy whereas eleanor during that
period of her life was still haunted by
the insecurities of her own childhood
where her mother had told her she was
ugly when she was a little girl and her
father was an alcoholic and the
mother-in-law sarah was being intrusive
about the kids and it was hard for her
to develop a full sense of herself
and so i think franklin felt attracted
to this happy young woman lucy mercer
but when confronted with the thought of
losing eleanor it was the last thing he
wanted
when did people back there in those days
uh
did
what did the public know did they know
about polio do they know about the
braces on his legs did they know about
lucy mercer do they know about missy
lehan do they know about princess martha
of norway well this is one of the most
interesting things to me in the world i
mean certain members of the press knew
about lucy mercer they knew that miss
lehan lived in the white house they knew
there were an unconventional set of
relationships in the white house they
certainly knew that roosevelt was a
paraplegic and yet there was then a
certain kind of sense that a president's
private life is his private life and
unless whatever he's doing has an impact
on his public activities i talked to one
old reporter who said who are we to
judge we're not angels ourselves so it
wouldn't be sporting somehow to report
on these unconventional relationships in
the white house and as far as the
paralysis goes what astonished me was
that the majority of the people thought
as i did that he was simply lame and the
reason they were allowed to feel that
way was that not a single newsreel ever
showed him in his wheelchair on his
braces being crippled there was almost
like an unspoken code of honor on the
part of the press that the president
wasn't to be seen that way and if a
young photographer came along and tried
to snap a pres a picture of the
president sometimes reporters would see
him being actually carried from it from
a car into a building like a child and
yet they never took a picture if a young
guy came along and tried to do that an
older guy would knock the camera to the
ground so as a result there was a kind
of dignity to the office of the
presidency then that i think is really
missing right now on both the side of
the press and the president roosevelt
understood the importance of holding his
private life secure he would never have
thought about talking about his mother's
domineeringness or his his feelings
about lucy mercer i mean there was a
reserve that i suspect served us better
at that time
you also talk about and it's been talked
about before you mean by volumes of mrs
roosevelt's daily column did she write
it herself oh did she ever write it
herself oh absolutely in fact if you
read them you can see the only way it
was possible for her to write that
column was really a recording of what
she did during the day and the only
reason the column worked
because it wasn't high thoughts it
wasn't great moments of issues but it
was so warm just as she was and it was
so full of activity because her schedule
was even more extraordinary than his
when you looked at those usher's diaries
her daily life would be three times as
long as franklin roosevelt's she never
stopped she traveled to migrant worker
camps she went into the mines there are
those famous cartoons of the miners
looking up and saying oh here comes
eleanor roosevelt she went to visit
blacks in the south she went to ccc
camps and that kind of traveling gave
her experiences that she could recount
in her daily column and just tell people
what she was thinking and feeling as she
met so many americans in the course of
her travels what would happen if you
took the roosevelt presidency and moved
it to modern day america
column every day radio show
you know handicapped
affairs and all that how much of this
would still be hidden it's really scary
to think about because if eleanor and
franklin had not been allowed that
network of friendships in the white
house that allowed them to sustain
themselves while they were going through
the difficult days of the depression and
the war they wouldn't have been as
strong as leaders as they were i'm
convinced that roosevelt needed the
relaxation for example as we said
earlier that missy could provide when
eleanor wasn't there but suppose the
press was saying who is this woman she's
his secretary she's in love with him
what's going on here at one point missy
had been involved with harry hopkins can
you imagine the press loving oh my god
harry's living there too is harry
involved with missy and i think in some
ways that if we hadn't had at that time
that kind of space for their private
lives they wouldn't have been
replenished as political leaders and so
too now the paralysis is more
interesting in some ways you almost wish
that roosevelt had the courage to go to
the public and say to the public i'm
crippled and it's okay because they
loved him so much in part because of his
courage and his strength but only at the
very end of his life did he ever give a
speech sitting down when he came back
from yalta he was so tired that he
finally excused himself instead of
standing on his braces and sat down and
for some reason that speech made an
enormous emotional impact on the country
because they then saw that he was
conquering this disability but at that
time nobody thought you could go to your
country and tell them that you were a
paraplegic that they wouldn't allow you
to be their president how much time did
he spend in warm springs georgia well
during the last
presidential years in the war he was
only down there three or four times but
prior to the war he went down every
thanksgiving because he had an annual
dinner for the patients at warm springs
he had originally created the whole warm
springs rehabilitation center in the
1920s he went down there initially
because the hot springs that came out of
the ground naturally in that area were
thought to help people with polio so he
created a whole rehab center and lots of
patients would be down there and i think
somehow his contagious confidence helped
them to get through their own polio and
so he liked to spend every thanksgiving
with them that was a pledge he had made
so you go to all these places yeah i
went to warm springs and what's so
amazing about it is that it is such a
primitive setting i mean you look at the
little white house which is what they
called the house where roosevelt would
stay and there's this tiny living room
dining room that's one combined room his
bedroom is the size of a twin you know
like a small boy's bedroom and then
there's one other bedroom that was where
missy lahan would stay in one other
guest room where eleanor would stay and
that's it and you keep thinking about
imagining much more luscious
surroundings for president of the united
states but he loved the simplicity of it
and it tells you a lot about him to see
that what about campo bello well
campbell bella was the place that had
been his mother's estate when he was a
young boy and it's up off the border of
maine and canada and it was a beautiful
summer home which had been very much a
part of eleanor and franklin's early
romantic days but it was also the place
where he got polio so that they didn't
really travel there much longer after
those early years they went there a lot
in the teens in the early 1920s but
after he got polio franklin's wife
eleanor would go up there a lot because
she loved it but he didn't go back there
very much after that what impact did it
have on him that he was an only child
absolute critical impact i mean he was
not only an only child but his father
was a sickly man from the time he was
young and his mother was a very young
mother who was told she could never have
other children after franklin was born
because it had been a tough birth so all
of her love which was large got focused
on this child and i think about it
sometimes i mean i think she gave him
probably the greatest asset a mother can
give a child that sense of unconditional
love but because he was so important to
her she never allowed him the freedom to
feel like he could stand apart from her
you have the feeling that she hovered
over him all of his life and even though
maybe that's the source of his
confidence one of my favorite quotes by
churchill says that when you met
roosevelt and i think sarah roosevelt
created this in her son he had such
inner elon such confidence such sparkle
that it was like opening your first
bottle of champagne to be around him and
i think that's a great gift a mother
gives a child but if only she'd known
when to separate i think he would have
had an easier time with intimacy with
other people
as you know if you go to
the hyde park residents the two big
chairs by the fireplace one is mark
sarah the other is mark franklin
no chair for eleanor oh exactly in fact
you go through as a tourist and the
hostess just says it to you as if it's
natural here's where sarah sat here's
where franklin's at then you say well
where did eleanor sit and they just say
oh wherever she could find a chair and
then you look at the dining room and
sarah was at one end as the hostess
franklin's at the other end as the host
and once again eleanor just had to find
a place wherever she could that house
that big house at hyde park as they
called it reflects that sarah remained
the mistress of that house throughout
all of their married life even after she
died there's this sad moment when
eleanor wants to change the house around
a little to make it her house now that
her mother-in-law is finally dead and
franklin can't bear the thought of
making any changes in his boyhood home i
know this isn't a book but it's a little
map that they give you at uh we'll get a
closer shot of it here at hyde park but
it shows the bedrooms
on the second floor uh you have franklin
delano roosevelt's bedroom and then
eleanor roosevelt's bedroom and that's
where his mother stayed
uh how often were they all there
together oh well sarah would always be
there when franklin and eleanor were
there and what's astonishing to look at
is the relative size of those bedrooms
when you see franklin's it's very large
it's spacious and you see sarah's it's
very large and spacious and eleanor has
a single bed in what must have been the
dressing room for one of the bedrooms in
between the two of them that's the part
of eleanor that she obviously didn't
have to take that small of a room but
there was a part of her that was a
martyr in a certain sense and liked to
have tough conditions to to live up to
as a challenge because she had been used
to those as a child and i found that
part very sad
harry hopkins died at age 55 i'm writing
i wrote this down when i was going
through your book lucy mercer died at
57. melvina thompson was
rose of eleanor secretary hernan
died at 61. princess martha died at 53.
yeah
uh lorena hickok died at uh i guess she
was 75.
anna the daughter died at 60 64 16.
well yeah she's pretty young too
how come
well harry hopkins just to start with
him
when he was um at the end of the new
deal period he was diagnosed with cancer
of the stomach and he had almost his
entire stomach removed but somehow
public life and public service gave him
an extra lease on life and when
roosevelt made him his foreign policy
adviser he somehow was able to get
through what most people would have died
from he was so sick during the war he
looked like he was dying he was so thin
his body was being eaten away and i
think what happened is after roosevelt
died and there was no longer room for
him in public life then he himself
finally died it was almost like
churchill said he was like a crumbling
lighthouse he was so full of fire and
energy it kept him alive but his body
was giving away on him to understand
what happened to princess martha i think
she too had had some illnesses during
her 40s and she died relatively young in
the fif in her 50s and so did lucy i
mean tuberculosis somehow spread and
something bad happened to them it seems
really strange especially now as we get
older these people seem much younger
dying than i would have thought when i
was younger how old was fdr when he died
fdr was 63 when he died and how old was
eleanor roosevelt eleanor lasted from
1882 to 1961.
so she's 70 something or other she
lasted an extra 17 years after fdr's
death uh the kids
how many kids were there that's not a
that's not a happy story in many ways
there were five children the daughter
anna was the oldest and then there were
four sons um jimmy elliot john
and um
and somebody who's named franklin
franklin jr and i think what happened is
it was hard for the for the five of them
to grow up in the shadow of that giant
oak of their parents
and for the four boy actually the five
children had a somewhat a combination of
18 marriages between them i think they
had a hard time apprenticing themselves
to becoming people in their own right
they wanted to skip steps and suddenly
become important run for senate run for
governor as we often see happening and
they never got their own confidence on
their own it's not an easy part of this
whole story
anna married twice her second husband
jumps out of a hotel room in new york
city right he was he was a manic
depressive and was under sedation for
his his psychological illness they had
already separated but he was always
troubled you can see it even during
their marriage they write each other
these amazingly romantic letters my one
and only you're the most precious i've
ever known you feel them clinging to
each other in an almost unnatural way
and shortly after the war her husband
whose name was john bodegar felt that he
no longer had the the platform of the
roosevelt presidency to stand on now
that roosevelt was dead and couldn't
make his way in the publishing world
anymore and got so sad that he jumped
out of a window and killed himself did
you interview john bodeger jr i talked
to all three of anna's children there
there was eleanor seagraves her oldest
daughter and a guy named curtis
roosevelt who's her second child and
then johnny bodiger jr the son
john
died at age 65 the son of fdr he had two
marriages but died a republican yes he
was the only one who became a republican
he actually became a republican pretty
early in his life much to the great
dismay of the family
fdr junior died at 74 married four times
right what was he like well he did have
his father's charm and people who knew
him said that when he smiled you could
see fdr and that sparkling personality
all over again and he did have some
success in politics and in fact was very
instrumental in john kennedy's
campaign in west virginia because
roosevelt was still a magic name in west
virginia at the time of the 1960
election and they sent fdr junior down
there to campaign for kennedy and it was
considered one of the things that turned
the tide elliot married five times eliot
married five times died at age 80 in
1990 what was he like well i did get a
chance to talk to him before he died and
again there'd be that twinkle in the
blue eyes that gave you a memory of
franklin roosevelt but he had had a
tough time finding himself i think the
alcoholism that was in eleanor's family
had visited itself upon elliott he had a
little bit of success in politics he was
a mayor in palm beach but mainly what he
did was he wrote mystery stories after a
while in which eleanor roosevelt was the
detective so there's always some dead
body and eleanor his mother becomes a
detective so and he wrote a series of
sort of tell-all books about the family
that all the other kids found very
disquieting james died at age 83 in 1991
ran democrats for nixon right
i mean you wonder what eleanor and
franklin would have thought he had four
marriages too now he had had some
success as a congressman for a while
from california um but then he never was
able to hold on to his career or to his
family very easily so it's not been an
easy time as i say for any of those
children
would you mind jumping to the end
and
telling as much as you can remember
about
the last couple of days of fdr well what
had happened was that after he came back
from the altar conference and after he
gave this major speech to the congress
in march of 1945 everybody could see
that his health was failing and somehow
when he went to warm springs georgia
there had always been this sense that he
would recuperate by going down there
that something about the air the beauty
the simplicity of the place so they
decided that he'd make an extended trip
to warm springs so at the end of march
he went down to warm springs and indeed
it did seem he brought with him his two
spinster cousins laura delano who's
these are characters too these cousins
and margaret suckly and they kept him
company and he didn't have that much
work to do when he was down there and
for the first week or so it seemed like
he might be getting a little bit of his
bounce back getting some weight back
because he was losing weight
tremendously in that last year and then
at a certain point he invited lucy
mercer to come and stay with him and she
arrived about four or five days before
he died stayed in a little guest house
right across the way from his little
white house and brought with her a
painter friend madame schumatov who
wanted to do a portrait of roosevelt
and then what happens is that he seems
to be getting better he takes these
little driving trips with lucy there was
his favorite place he had dowdell's knob
where you could see the whole valley in
georgia from that place and lucy later
wrote that she'd never forget that day
when he talked to her about all the
plans he had after the presidency was
over and what he hoped to do with the
world and how he had still idealism left
about what the world would be like after
the war was over
but then on a certain morning on april
12th he woke up and people surprisingly
thought that he looked better than he
had for weeks his color was radiant
almost probably it was as doctors later
said that the embolism that later killed
him was already beginning to be felt in
his skin and his coloring but he
nevertheless kept everybody company he
was a wonderful storyteller so all that
some all that morning he was talking to
lucy and her friend madame schumertof
who was painting a portrait of him at
that time the two spinster cousins are
there and then suddenly in the middle of
talking to them at about noon or so on
april 12th he just suddenly said i have
a terrific headache
and he slumped forward and one of the
cousins went over to him thinking he had
dropped his cigarette or something and
then she realized that he had become
unconscious so immediately they called
for doctors they called for help and
they carried him into his bedroom and
lucy knew enough to leave at that moment
in time she knew she shouldn't be there
so she and madame schumatov did leave
but then what happened is he died about
an hour and a half later he never
regained consciousness
and they finally called eleanor and told
her she was in the middle of giving a
speech in washington when she found out
and she knew she said the minute the
phone rang that something had happened
she could just feel it and they didn't
tell her that he had died they just said
you have to come back to the white house
immediately they called her away from
the day they called her away from the
diet she was actually had just finished
giving a speech and someone was doing a
piano concert that she was listening to
so she excused herself again she had
this amazing presence and said i must
leave now but i'll be back to see you at
some point she went to the white house
and they told her that he had died
so she immediately called for harry
truman the vice president to come so she
could give the news to harry truman and
that's one of those celebrated moments
in history when truman says to her is
there anything i can do for you and her
first response is no but is there
anything i can do for you for you're the
one in trouble now but then she had the
presence of mind to ask him was it
ethical for her to use a government
plane to go down to warm springs to see
her husband's body and of course truman
provided that for you can't imagine
people even asking that today so she
gets down to warm springs georgia and as
you would do when there's a death like
this she asked her cousins who were
there laura delano in particular tell me
everything that happened in the last 24
hours and laura i believe had always
loved fdr and probably always been
jealous of eleanor for she maliciously
decided to tell eleanor that lucy had
been there she didn't have to nobody
would have told eleanor she just said
maybe she would have found out anyway
and then when pushed further she elected
to tell her that lucy had been at the
white house that last
year and that anna her daughter had been
the one to make those arrangements i i
can't even imagine what it must have
been like for eleanor to have to present
the strong face to the world that she
did by getting in that train and going
back with her husband on that famous
train ride from warm spring to
washington knowing inside this deep hurt
that she felt
when when she got to the white house
anna was there and all that anna could
say was as her mother confronted her
really angrily how could you do this to
me all that anna said later she could
say was i didn't know what to do i loved
you both and i felt caught in a
crossfire and anna later said that she
was sure that their relationship had
been destroyed forever she thought she
had lost her mother and then what
happened i knew i didn't want to end the
book at that point even though a death
is a natural place to end it because i
just felt so sad at that conjury of
emotions so i decided to follow the
story through the summer and the fall of
45 after his death and then thank god
what i was able to find is that as
eleanor traveled the country again that
summer
everywhere she went people kept telling
her how much they loved her husbands
people that she had thought were her
people the poor people taxi drivers
porters felt that their lives were so
much better off at the end of the war
than at the start and she'd been
fighting him all through the war she
wanted the war to be a vehicle for
social reform on civil rights on daycare
and the factories she kept wanting more
than he could provide but now she saw
she later said in the summer of 45 that
the country was indeed a better place
that blacks had worked in factories they
never had before they'd done well in the
military that women had this great sense
of mastery from having been 60 percent
of the workforce during the war
veterans were going to college on the gi
bill of rights unions were stronger than
ever before and she said as she heard
all these tales she began to feel a
sense of how much the country owed to
franklin roosevelt and as she felt that
she was somehow amazingly able to
forgive him for what had happened
and then finally in august of 45 after
the bomb was dropped she was able to go
to and the war came to an end she was
able to go to anna her daughter and
forgive her as well affording a
reconciliation between the two of them
that really lasted for the rest of their
lives and i must say as a biographer
when i learned that my heart just felt
so full in knowing this woman has done
something i'm not sure i could have done
could i have the kind of spirit to
forgive such a deep hurt like that but
it was so wonderful for her that she did
because it meant that the rest of her
life those next 17 years instead of
harboring bitterness toward her husband
she loved him even more than in some
ways than in life and she was able to
incorporate all of his strengths into
herself she had always been the
idealistic one in the relationship and
he was the practical one she always said
she was the one who thought about what
should be done and he thought about what
could be done but now somehow after he
died she became partly more like him she
was a much better politician after his
death than before because now she had to
be both of them not just herself
so it was an amazing end to this story
and it makes you realize you know if you
looked at this story from the outside in
as the media would probably do today
they'd accuse him of infidelity they
might accuse him of harassment for his
relationship with his secretary missy
lahan maybe accuse anna of betrayal of
her mother and yet none of those labels
would be right i mean i'm absolutely
convinced these people never meant to
hurt one another they were simply trying
to get through their lives with the best
possible mixture of love and respect
through work and affection and it seems
to me that that challenge is not to do
what's so prevalent today in biography
to expose and to label and to stereotype
what i really wanted to try and do was
to extend empathy to understand why they
needed all these relationships and not
to judge them harshly because of their
own human needs
you uh have some uh references to the
fact that she went in
to
stand by his body at warm springs
wanted some moments by herself and then
when she got to the white house she did
the same thing and the ushers kept
everybody out how did you find that out
one of the ushers at the white house who
was there when she asked him to close
the door was actually inside the room
and he wrote in a memoir that he saw
that as she stood by the body she opened
the casket one last time so that she
could say goodbye to him privately and
he was standing right there and he wrote
it in a memoir and so too people at warm
springs wrote memoirs about those last
minutes everybody kept somewhat of a
diary during that period of time i think
knowing how important it would be for
later history you also include a letter
between lucy mercer
and anna where did you get that well
that letter was actually in anna's
papers at the fdr library had that ever
been published before there was one
johnny bottiger jr the son of anna had
written a wonderful little book about
his mother and his father and his
father's death and that's the first time
i'd ever seen that letter published
what's so wonderful about the letter is
that after fdr died anna felt so bereft
during that period of time because she
thought she lost both her father and her
mother and at some point she called lucy
and lucy then maybe three or four weeks
after fdr's death lucy writes back this
fabulous letter just saying what that
call meant because she too was feeling
totally out of it here's this man that
she had loved had been such a good
friend to her and she couldn't even
express publicly or openly anything
about their relationship she's not part
of the funeral she's just off on her own
but in that letter she says to anna i
want you to know how much your father
loved you and she tells anna it's such a
generous letter how many times anna's
father fdr had talked to lucy about how
much he loved his daughter and for a
daughter who had lost her father so much
to hear that confirmed i guess was so
important that anna's daughter told me
that anna kept that letter in her
bedside table for the rest of her life
because somehow it confirmed not only
how much her father loved her but maybe
confirmed her not feeling too guilty
about putting lucy together with her
father because it shows what a wonderful
woman lucy was do you ever find yourself
getting emotional about any of this oh
absolutely i mean not only emotional but
you know you live with these characters
for six years it took me longer to work
on this book and i'm afraid than the war
to be fought that was what was pretty
embarrassing i would find myself talking
to franklin and ellen or talking to
harry hopkins and lorena hickok to anna
as if they were still alive i mean you
really feel their presence and when bad
things happen to them when one of them
hurts one another you feel it i mean
that's the only way you can do it when
you get so absorbed in all of this
where'd you write it mostly at home i
have a study right on the second floor
of my house we live right on the main
street in concord so it's wonderful you
can walk right into the town and i
filled the study with pictures of
franklin and eleanor with pictures of
the war rosie the riveter and pictures
of the women going to work in the
factory so that the ambiance felt like
world war ii and i got all the books i
could find on this era i wanted them
with me this time i love libraries and
usually use libraries
a lot but in this case i wanted to be
able to have the books as much presence
i went to every used bookstore and so
the whole room was filled with roosevelt
and world war ii book so it was a great
place to work how do you write i fear i
write in longhand i am so primitive
still i cannot think on the typewriter
i've never been able to so i write it
all out in longhand and then the worst
stage is i then copy it all over so that
a typist can read the writing and that's
when i edit when i copy it all over and
then i gave it to a typist who would
type it up and on a computer and give it
back to me and then i didn't really look
at it all until the whole first draft
was done and then finally at the very
end when i had to really edit the thing
we put it all on my husband's computer
and he taught me how to actually work on
the computer to edit i'm not sure i can
still write on it originally because i
don't think i can think on it but at
least i've learned how to edit on the
computer so i felt very proud what time
of day do you write usually i start
early in the morning my husband and i
both get up really early for some
reason he awakens like at 5 30 or 6 in
the morning so he gets me up to go have
breakfast with him and sometimes we work
out if we're in one of those moves which
we're not always in and then we both
start working pretty early even
sometimes before the kids go to school
at seven o'clock and work until like the
middle of the afternoon and then can go
play tennis or go do errands i mean
that's the fun thing about having a
husband who's in the same line of
business you can take your breaks
together
now when you the actual writing set to
six years the whole research project and
everything else how long did it actually
take you to write it i would guess of
the six years probably four of them were
research and two of them were writing
and even in the last two years of
writing i still needed to do more
research you'd come upon something and
you wouldn't know the answer to it you'd
have to go back to hyde park so i was
probably at the library there within
weeks of finishing the book
your favorite thing in the book
i think my favorite thing in the book is
the discovery that eleanor and franklin
still loved each other during this
period of time the conventional wisdom
among historians was that after the
affair with lucy mercer in 1918 their
marriage had become a pure political
partnership and i was so happy to
discover even though it meant
discovering that they could still hurt
each other during this period that there
were still alive emotions they were
yearnings they kept missing each other i
almost felt like i wanted to push them
together because i could feel that love
between them but i was very glad to find
that out you knew lyndon johnson you
wrote a book on him worked for him did
you know john f kennedy no i met him
once when i was a young girl i knew the
family pretty well but not johnny
yes
and did you what's the closest you got
to the roosevelts i guess the closest i
got i never saw franklin or eleanor
personally the closest i got were their
two sons who i interviewed before they
died and then all the children of those
children who were really very helpful to
me of the three books and all the
thinking about these politicians
who's your favorite well i think i'll
probably always be most grateful to
lyndon johnson but not for the reasons
that you might think i think watching
him in those last years of his life when
i was with him on his ranch helping him
on his memoirs was such a searing
experience to see a man who had no other
resources in his life but politics he
didn't know how to get through the days
without politics he used to have mock
meetings in the morning to figure out
what to do during the day and it would
be which
cows were going to be given the itch
medicine which um tractors were going to
be used that day he had to have meetings
like he had in the white house but no
longer is it bills on the hill it's the
ranch it was almost like a crazy setting
for him and at night he couldn't go to
sleep until he knew how many people were
coming through the lbj
library he wanted more people to go
through that library than we're going
through the kennedy library so after a
while he'd say get him in free donuts
free coffee anything but basically what
i saw was a man who was so sad that he
couldn't even be alone when he i'd be
down there he'd ask me to stay outside
his room when he took a nap he would
wake me up at 5 30 in the morning to
talk to him and when you're 23 years old
i think you think that the end of the
most exciting thing in the world would
be to become president of the united
states and yet i saw in him somebody who
had not balanced that success with
family with love with friendship with
sports with anything else so that it
left him so bereft at the end that i
think the impact it had on me was to
make me know that success at that price
wouldn't be worth it and not long after
that experience of watching him die i
got married and had children and i think
one of the reasons it takes me so long
to write these books is that i wanted to
be with those kids while they were
little i didn't want to ever be left
like lyndon johnson with 700 books at
the end of my life but nothing else in
it so there's no question that that had
such an impact when president carter was
president he asked me to be the head of
the peace corps it was something i would
have loved to do at some other time but
the kids were little and i just
remembered lyndon johnson and i didn't
even feel sad not being able to do it
because i knew the kids would be grown
all too quickly and i didn't want to end
up that way so nothing can ever compete
with that probably where were you born
in rockville center new york
rockefeller center no not rockefeller
rockville center
no that's okay my family originally came
from brooklyn and then moved out to long
island and that's why i was a huge
baseball fan my real love of history
started with baseball because my father
taught me to keep score when i was seven
years old and somehow i would recreate
the games for him when he came home from
work the brooklyn dodger games and i
thought without me he'd never know what
happened to the brooklyn dodgers because
he never told me all the scores were in
the newspaper the next day so i was so
proud of what i was doing every day and
that's probably where i started to love
history where did you go to college i
went to colby college in maine and then
i went to harvard graduate school and
got a phd in government at harvard what
was your thesis on my thesis was in
constitutional law actually it was on
two attempts to overturn supreme court
decisions um dirksen on on the prayer in
the schools and the um one man one vote
decision and in both cases the
amendments failed
i'm gonna write another book oh sure
what else can i do
my husband and i are actually going to
work on a book together which may be a
disaster i remember interviewing
president carter once and he said the
biggest mistake he made was working on a
book with his wife rosalind they almost
got divorced but we're going to do a
book together on presidential decisions
and take about 15 decisions like truman
firing macarthur and lincoln at fort
sumter johnson getting civil rights
through the congress each one will
illustrate a different power of the
presidency and each one will be told as
a story i want each one to be a dramatic
moment in that president's life
so that a young person reading it like
in college would get a history of the
presidency but through these great
decisions so i'm hoping they'll love
history as much as we do what do you
kids think of all this well you know the
interesting thing is because we've been
home so much of the time when we work
they haven't really seen the end results
until now as teenagers they see this
book out they see their father in the
quiz show movie and as being played as a
27 year old one of them came out of the
movie said dad you're a stallion again
you know somehow that sense of pride so
that it isn't like a career where
they're confronting daily
who their parents are we've been much
more quiet and at home i do television
at home so people are much more aware
because i do local commentary for our
abc affiliate in boston and do a weekly
television show which i've done for 12
years when we go on the streets people
will know me from that so the kids are
sort of queasy about getting stopped all
the time but as far as the writing goes
it's been the most fabulous thing to
combine with family life because we're
home almost all the time
we haven't got much time but you know
when you go up to fdr's home and you see
the library and the home and then val
kill which is a couple of miles
away where eleanor roosevelt spent a lot
of her time what was your thoughts about
what kind of a family feeling would that
have been she over there and him over at
the other place and the thing that's so
striking in seeing the two separate
places is how different they are the big
house of sarah and franklin's is so
perfectly put together that china all
matches all the furniture is gorgeous
eleanor's house has all mixed china
every chair in the living room is a
different size so that a fat person and
a tall person a thin person and a short
person would be comfortable in the
chairs you know how opposite their
temperaments was she was a much more she
liked to make people feel at ease and he
loved the elegance i think of that first
place so in some ways they were never
meant for each other but thank god for
the country and for themselves these
opposite temperaments attracted when
they were young and had enough to keep
them going through this long marriage i
know we this is not fair with a minute
to go but how about the relationship
between her women
friends at val kill
lot's been written about that what do
you think the relationship was i think
it's mostly a relationship where eleanor
was loved by somebody particularly
lorena hickok for the first time she
felt the center of somebody else's life
i know some people have claimed that
that means that maybe she was a lesbian
as this woman lorena hickok was i don't
think that's necessarily so i think the
most important thing to understand is
that this woman loved her and she loved
her and helped her to become a better
first lady the truth is historians don't
know whether they went beyond hugs and
kisses and sometimes people try to
appropriate eleanor one way or the other
but i think eleanor would be the first
person if she came back today and knew
that if she were considered a lesbian
and it gave a role model to younger
people making them feel better about
themselves she'd probably be the first
to say that's fine but i don't think she
would have ever defined herself that way
no ordinary time is the
title of this book it's about the war
years on the home front with fdr and
eleanor roosevelt here you have doris
kearns goodwin thank you very much oh
you're so welcome
no ordinary time is available in
paperback from simon schuster on the web
at simonsays.com
next week on encore book notes rhode
island jurist frank williams author of
judging lincoln
for information about any authors and
books feature